I heard that you had been in contact
with the other cast members of the
office yeah it's really been nice
there's just a text Shane that that
started up I think somebody had just
sort of a question for everyone early on
and and then of course everyone just
started jumping in with memes and jokes
and comments and it's been really nice
there's something very nostalgic and I
mean a lot of us are in touch anyway but
just to have everybody kind of riffing
at the time it's it's it's really really
cool this pandemic has brought a lot of
people closer together ironically we're
distanced but we're communicating a lot
more now we're calling up friends we
haven't talked to in a long time we're
zooming people so it's nice to think of
the cast of the office is no different
you guys are all just pinging each other
back and forth yeah you know I hear so
often from fans how much that show means
to them and what a comfort it is to them
and that of course means so much to me
but I also I share that with them right
it's something that for all of us that
were involved in making that show it was
it was an incredible time it was like a
just a magical time and work we all have
deep nostalgia for it not just the
episodes as they turned out but the
actual community cos yeah making that
show and it just was there were no bad
apples it was an incredible cast you
know so many of the cast to that show
they're just wonderful wonderful people
[Music]
I'd say about a third of you really good
people and the rest absolute monsters
and you know what I'm talking about
because you're one of them because
you're one of the monsters for the only
one saying how wonderful everyone is
whenever ed Helms is saying it was just
not a bad apple in the group you know
he's the bad apple yeah he's the one let
me make sure I get the word out that you
got a watch
whiskey sour happy hour every Wednesday
okay this is from April 22nd to May 13th
at the bluegrass situation calm on bgs
facebook and youtube it's also a
fundraiser so that we're raising money
for two incredible organizations music
cares and Direct Relief so and the
donate buttons are active terrific
through the duration too so
so enjoy the show and also give some
money to some great causes very good